you know what is upset broken are you
doing good are you in a character sorry
ah that's all I like it
your Beach Batman yes definitely the way
I would pop on the gun it's a bear and
drugs is bottom bottom way step broken
you kick [ __ ] ass by the way thank
you so [ __ ] funny man
you kick [ __ ] ass my man anyways my
question to you is what was your most
awkward moment while producing the
preacher TV show um I'm just so
distracted by this guy he looks like
Johnny Depp behind you kind of go back
to that shot switch cameras yeah I see
yeah
most awkward moment while producing the
show honestly was trying to get the cast
to do this table read that we just can't
become probably the hardest thing we've
had to do the entire season but I'm glad
that it turned out so well I'm glad you
guys all came to hit so welcome to San
Diego comic-con applause
this question is for the entire panel
and how would you use Genesis on this
Hall age crowd and what would you say oh
good question
do I count I'm just gonna bear in mind
these people in direct same but a
knowledge every nice everyone stop Shaq
go and cause the biggest orgy of all
time to recap it would be in their capes
everywhere capes and makeup everywhere
I've come amongst you like syphilis and
chlamydia
mr. plop simplistic black that's what
are you sinner
yeah got problems all right hello thank
you my name is Laura I'm from Brazil
and my question is for Joseph big family
word I have a Miss Vista too I want to
show you get out of time what is that oh
nice yeah and one of the many things I
might say about Cassidy that kind of
reminds me of Rudy yeah so I want to
know what do you see
oh Rudy in Cassidy well I think you know
why I think when I started this job I
think my idea was so I think it's really
[ __ ] Layla they were just gonna be
Rudy with an Irish accent I could do a
bit of an Irish accent and I kept on
that guy and unsuccessful okay Reese I'm
a little bit
like you can't can't do that I'm not one
of them back to do so if plans I saw
fairly happy to go along so and you know
I don't do all that thinking [ __ ] too
busy how masturbate and playing college
area a lot of [ __ ] going on
so I'm snowed on them I'm scrolling I
don't be I because of all this I was so
much working to do it about telling
honest to go it's all we do one is the
male ones anyway and you may love
journey and today has been a nightmare
can only get in school are you the
novelty wears up you ask in college tell
use an [ __ ] sorry does that no answer
any of it I feel like answered baby
God he looks book and tarry by everyone
well seven I saw a sausage party last
night thanks for that thank you
that's amazing so my question is this
being a freshman show being in this
first season I was surprised at how
ambitious filmmaking was especially like
even shows like Game of Thrones and
Breaking Bad they take a while to show
their ambition creativity as it gets
better as it goes on but were you guys
are surprised right from the start so
I'm just wondering what are some of the
influence the linking influences to the
show and we suspect the style that you
guys have stamped on it to be wall for
the next couple seasons hopefully we
watched a lot of Kill Bill yeah we
watched a lot of tarantino stuff some
wes anderson stuff we watched a lot of
guess I'm kind of Wes Anderson we put in
there so Sergio Leone we watch watch
terrence malick we watch Big Lebowski
watch stupidity we watch the rail eat a
lot we watched old kung fu movies and we
watched a lot of westerns and a lot of
scorsese we really wanted to try to
combine every style and tone and its
directors it was like an incredible
opportunity to really see what we were
able to do if we were actually able to
kind of create a show that had a
infrastructure that could spin all these
plates at once basically and kind of go
from one tone and style to the next you
know hopefully somewhat seamlessly and
so yeah all that stuff but we want tons
of movies and then just blatantly ripped
them off
we are handsome look at him very
handsome
hello boy sighs no fancy a shower after
this boy buzzshock up for this Joe shags
first and axe first banished state
affairs come on
let me give you put in here please sorry
Johnny Depp like that one
no romantic he's talking okay Jonny dad
mom sorry my question how did Jesse and
Cassidy develop such a strong friendship
so fast
what white why do we think they did I
think
have you met Joe you're all his best
friend now exactly it's gone man be
honest Samantha and me actually I just
feel very much Castle castle Jesse just
he's his name let me get up to some
cheap monoxide when we get drunk and
yeah don't involve me on this we're very
similar
tell me you know you seemed it was it
seems as though we shouldn't you always
with unpaired berries it's all wanker
but when you made a satyr old thing
honestly like out the best time we're
doubling can roof and even when it [ __ ]
even when it should be stressful we did
we going very well
I don't know what you mean the
characters you mean how to how do we
manage it as as cars week and I think
they they also well anything that they
just definitely need need one another's
rights Oregon we do a lot of kissing
behind roofs back yeah gentle packing
manly boy you can get series he's not a
jungle woman really Quadra it's nothing
to laugh at encourage it say something
Scott right question don't involve a
minute yeah my questions for Seth and
Evan
re I'm grateful for what you've done
with the show but I really didn't like
what you did with Ling just do it
say I'm gonna go God okay let's harlot a
[ __ ] out now it's the time so julep is
it a great strong character at the
beginning she comes in makes bazookas
she says you have to fight like a lion
but then in Episode four
she gives drugs to Cassidy drops her
pants and says have your way with me
even though she's supposed to be in love
with custard why does she do that
self T stroke on you dig haha okey now
huh
yeah and Joe's answering it I don't know
about
yeah I think that's exactly what it is
she's very self-destructive person and a
lot of people on both sides of those you
know that they they directly destroy the
thing that thing that they should not be
destroying and they feed the bad side
their instincts instead of the good side
and they get resentful towards people
and so they act out and son in that way
and and and I don't think I don't think
that's like a huge deal for tulip either
on the grand scale and like things she's
done throughout her their last few
months you know I think I think that you
know when you're stressed of when things
are not going well when you're in a bad
place emotionally I think that you
return to what is familiar and for
Judith what is familiars it's chaos
perhaps not making the best decisions
and I think that's I quite like that
bees actually because it shows quite
startling and how vulnerable she is yeah
I think a lot of people think that in
order to have a strong female character
you can't have a very flawed human
character we don't think that
and the best characters are applauded
and do things that anger you and found
you with times and and and we didn't
want to live to not have all those sides
to her if she was just an ass-kicking
bazooka maker who would get real thin
real fast I'm a bloody good shot no I
won't see what outside so I'm a huge fan
of Garth's work it was his work on
preacher and later on cross that made me
fall in love with comics forever and so
with that in mind I want to know from
him as well as anyone on a panel wants
to you know speak up with all the
deviations from the books to the screen
what are your favorites and which ones
made you the most nervous to put out
what my favorite should be the scenes
slaughtering everybody Jesse and
Cassidy's first meeting to live in the
cornfield the fight in hotel I love that
they've basically solved all the
storytelling problems of the comic onto
them breathless million miles an art
piece that wouldn't have worked if
you've done it done a direct adaptation
I feel that the thing is in great hands
with the cast with Seth and Evan with
unsung hero Sam Kaplan who is the guy
who really makes it grinds it finds
sensible reasons for things that I used
to chop in there hoping for the best
creature was I mean I did start writing
at 20
years ago it
it's a strange base and it's full of all
sorts of weird ingredients but things
that work in a comic don't necessarily
work when you see them actually be gonna
front of you and filmed all those
problems have been solved by these guys
and I applaud them my question is for
Ruth I really love the character to live
and I'm wondering if you could talk a
little bit more about your feelings with
her I can you said you really like that
she's hot and she makes bad decisions
but um you know how she can be
vulnerable and caring with her uncle or
even with the friendship with Emily um
and then you know meeting Cassidy
because she was trying to kill somebody
and also after the first episode did you
go learn how to make a bazooka I did
train bazooka training pretty heavy was
impeachments um I I mean III enjoy it
with other playing tutor but I think
this thing about his sous-chef sort of
and she breaks my heart of it um and I
find I find it so interesting that she
has sort of created this shield his
armor for herself because she's had a
sort of
look out for herself her entire life but
what I really love about her show is he
sees flashes of vulnerability and these
flashes of kindness you know she may not
know how to through be affectionate or
show love but she does try you know and
she's never
she's never patronizing you know the
kids she really does enjoy her company
and I love those gentle moments and I
think that you see at most when you know
she tries to rehabilitate Cassidy you
know I mean she may sort of like play
with him and toy with him and but I'm
either like him kids in kindergarten and
they but I think that that just shows
how there is a lot of identification
with younger dog with her and I think at
rest that she's she's she's trying to
figure things out it's you know as well
she's trying to figure out who she is
and have her place in this world
especially because she sees them Jesse
now is is making choices that might not
necessarily involve her and she finds a
terrifying makes her question her own
sort of screwed up morality because I
think for so much of her life she's kept
those sort of questions at bay and so
it's good it's interesting like to see
her face with things maybe she doesn't
want to do
another this I go up so long I'm going
to ruin my career I understand how hard
it is
anything is oh yeah what's your number
one piece of advice for somebody who
wants to have as much fun than success
as you have in the entertainment embrace
share not you know honest to god like
it's very difficult and read reading in
and honestly like I know I can't seem
like my job your character mother there
is a much like acid is a real [ __ ]
dark side there I get terribly depressed
well I obviously do I have to just [ __ ]
off and when leaving the woods roommates
don't think and get really hard work so
but I think for anyone who suffers like
that and urge you to embrace it and
there's nothing wrong with being
completely knows it's so people so
[ __ ] boring man you know you know
ADHD it's just a level one really I mean
[ __ ] know what they've been gone enough
to give me a key like so medically I now
have to be forgiven by everyone job
ain't a good look for work I yeah I'm on
our wing today well I have this area
it's not right to not understand it but
yeah I urge anyone anyone with ADHD
anyone would buy all the who suffers
like that I just think embrace if I'm
talking virus to 2016 and Cebu's go in
off Christ
I
my name is JT huge fan of the show
really love it um what would have pulps
me about it is that it's just he's one
of the Hudson you know what you go to
spend on all the day you see them really
handsome lads on scooters he looks out
of them really on someone's another did
sorry God see were you ever mention
anyone oppose you yes continue to shine
I mean it's a very weird show and it
does take a lot of turns for the better
and I mean I really enjoy the show it
kind of reminds me of a Twinkie where it
shouldn't work the ingredients shouldn't
work but it really does kinda taste good
look attack their shelf you must the
[ __ ] lay off Twitter [ __ ]
Millennials
I really you know I like I you know I
love the show oh but uh I was wondering
how do you think this affects those
other kind of you know not as popular
and say something like Spider Man or
something like that but still justice
you know good even better how do you
think this is going to affect other
Marvel and DC in underground comics so
be put on the big screen and the small
screen you gotta follow the essentially
I think I get it I hope it helps I guess
does that kind of answer your question
uh no not at all you should go ahead I
think I don't know I hope that people
will see that we people consider
creature unable for like a decade at
least and so the fact that we showed it
wasn't and that people seem to like it
maybe we'll take other comics that
people have considered to be unfaithful
and will inspire people to make them and
will inspire the people
I don't say that Garth in a lot of
comics and now that we have is here
we're not going to stop at this
you know exact but I don't think the
marble I don't think the people of
marbling to know the shows we don't
concern you get the directing gig on
Deadpool for exactly hi guys my name is
Kane I first want to thank all of you
guys for bringing creature to life it
just does my heart good it's been a long
time coming in Garth I got to work with
you on a short film that you directed
stitched I was on the crew for that and
I got to share a drink or more with you
afterwards and kind of pick your brain
about creature and got to care about the
challenges of translating this and with
that I see online there's a lot of
nitpicking and from everything
everything from why does Jessie have a
beard why's it tulip blonde
why doesn't Cassie have sunglasses on
all the time and how you guys handle
that because it drives me insane I can't
imagine how its you guys feel to me what
what cons in the end of the day is
whether or not the thing works
and we just got a sec this season which
means I understand what you love
something to the extent that a lot of
people love creature you're going to be
thrown off a bit by the changes but
certain things have to go to make the
thing work and that's what you've got to
keep in your head
when you're thinking about any
adaptation I don't see anything that
bothers me what that means are the
people online I don't know but at the
end of the day so far beyond our control
that it's it's crazy I think to worry
about it also anything I'm overwhelmed
by how positive the reaction we made the
[ __ ] Green Hornet dude like I mean on
the grand scale of things like this has
been a dream as far as how people have
been embracing it and how critics simply
embraced it and our audiences seem to
like it and how true fans for the most
part really seem to like it and
obviously the kings of annoying but if
anything I don't look at the reaction
and think like van efficient people off
I'm generally look at the reaction to
things like we've done a much better job
of winning people over that I ever
thought we would and that we ever have
in the past so
my question is AMC is obviously had a
huge amount of success with the Walking
Dead and how much do you think that
influence getting creature Alec
production health and did it result in
AMC giving you more freedom or more
notes I mean listen I don't think the
show would have happened if that show
didn't exist it certainly paved the way
and also taught AMC how to deal with
like a giant world like that and made
them really good partners to work with
yeah they've been great and I think yeah
I mean it was the perfect you know he
was exactly in Albie's it was a comic
that was very very popular among comic
book fans it was a comic you probably
hadn't heard of if you weren't a comic
book fan and then he made it something
huge you know and so it for sure is what
one of the things that let us think is
really possible at all was we could
point in that they did it what kind of
freedom together did that wrecker train
you in it could be and if you see it
it's crazy
like okay not really there's not it
seems like there's nobody reigning you
in it though they there was a few
conversations that had to be had from
time to time in general you know you
don't just blow up Tom Cruise without a
phone call so there was there was some
there was conversations it's not like in
movies where you have the MPAA which is
just it's like faceless like Borg like
organization where you just like send
your movie to them and pray that it
comes back with the right rating with
this it's like a guy calls you it's like
you really need to blow up Tom Cruise or
like we think it'd be funny he's like
okay
that's like kind of how it goes like
it's been really yeah AMC the only thing
that they keep saying is if it's for the
story if it makes the characters better
to progresses things better because of
the violence but you know no totally
unnecessary violence but they let us
just do whatever really it's great
my name is Andre I'm cam Thompson just
found the light fight Joe I think the
dog is outside you got any dials about
hooking or not when I'm putting all last
night a cocktail party thanks for
ruining big hurts for me here not good a
more direct question we've seen bits and
pieces of Jesse's backstory with
interacting with his father
are we going to see any kind of extra
with Cassidy um that is a part of the
comics and I mean we I mean again we're
just starting to put together the next
season but ideally yeah I mean we would
hope one of the things again that I
think the most happen with the
infrastructure we've set up is we we've
set up a show that could start in Dublin
150 years ago for the first 10 minutes
of an episode and you and you go into
that world and that's something that's
very exciting to us so ideally we'll
really explore I mean we really work fan
to the competent so we want to do
everything that we liked about the comic
it might not be done the exact same way
it might take a different route to get
there
but like me and Evan have a checklist in
our heads away everything that we
thought was dope about the comics and
we're like all that shit's got to be in
the show somewhere and so yeah
everything that you I really think that
at the end of the day people will be
surprised at how much we've been able to
include from the comic not how much is
diverted from the Misaka clapping
perfunctory but how does that have a
definition of perfunctory yes as a
chorus found how far you think AMC will
let you go
you're the most serious guy and weird
out I've ever seen now make stuff and go
super mega take it out have some fun
we hide a lot of the mud phone cut up
that's a good head but you're like you
could [ __ ] about oh okay anyway I asked
however I think AMC will let you go with
the show as far as how SEO by being next
season
again they have so far been very
encouraging of all of our plans and
we're just starting to eat out the next
season but they are everyone very
excited about the dredging that's going
to soften the teaser you know they're
all in the car together which is
probably what a lot
what happened around 10 hours ago and
we're lucky that some of the heads of
AMC are genuine creature fans and that's
one of the reasons that show happened
so do we Joel still remembers like huge
fans so like they want it to be rad - I
like truly care
you